this video was produced and financed in
collaboration with the divergent
Allegiant series
Hansel hey yo it's your ball P to the
paw up in this VR crib we're gonna play
some Allegiant first time we're checking
out this via future technology but
before we begin the divergent series
hits theaters this Friday March 18 but
wait it's already available in UK what
are you doing get out there go watch it
it's also available in several other
countries like France see it this
weekend reserve your tickets today
time to Enter the Matrix oh hey I waited
84 years to be inside the spaceship and
finally I am here there's a circle of
space that I can oh [ __ ] okay I am going
to open the door oh my god that's
[ __ ] weird
Hey what that's cool
hey hey oh my god am I supposed to go
down there because I don't have links oh
my god
it's sergeant beautiful it's like Jake
Jake is on you good you're here
I yeah you didn't look at me but thank
you I'm for your Washington forget it
no universe you know oh I'm so close
you're fired trust someone else coming
up hey girl what's up oh my god it's the
girl from the movie divergent I feel hot
or too close to that oh hi guys hey I
still believe in the plan yeah I am
looking everybody I'm sorry it's VR hey
guys what exactly did Kim how's it going
up there he discovered something devious
your body traitor
I'm a pincher but it sounds like become
a picture of my brother
I'm a finisher but god this game to turn
me instantly into a pervert this is not
my fault can we edit that out we're all
here okay oh Jesus Christ
clock is ticking oh it's a beautiful
Chilean that's rookie okay we're going
I'll were in a trial go everyone listen
up
oh god she's coming close again this is
weird uh guys I know a Swedish massage
if anyone is interested against Chicago
you guys need to relax
stop being so tense
don't worry it's gonna be okay to do
that you'll need to use the terminal
right over there I'll do that don't
worry buddy I got it
look at this I did that I did that you
guys are [ __ ] welcome oh my god
Crowley's room
okay enough to watch the charm of this
game ah smells like carrots
the future is bright
oh sorry the future is definitely oh my
god that is really interesting okay oh
my god I am if she farts right now I'm
gonna look Oh God okay okay sorry I'm
sorry
can I smell her armpits we may decide
which device for going to plant Oh blow
it up
flowers rookie time to step up and be
one of us hand me the device you honest
ears uh which device I don't really care
but um yeah I just go with this thing
anyone oh this is cool hey you guys
wanted this you want this ah that's too
bad boom
okay here we go killing everyone oh my
god what I'm doing do I look as cool as
I feel right now do I look cool I feel
like I do take this yeah this is getting
really heavy guys I don't know how long
I can hold it up I'll ever go get
removing I'm shooting the couch now Oh
God that's : hey guys how's it going hi
guys how's it going down here you guys
aren't doing [ __ ] are you I did it
hey hey what's up guys it's Buddha pie
okay he's looking at me hey it's been a
pleasure serving by your sides
brofist thank you you did a good job I
can't wait to see you guys in the movie
and so not you so much you got a bit of
a diva problem you guys you're cool your
armpit smells great you have a great
butt and this is Peter Pye signing off
that was amazing and now I don't even
want to live in real life anymore guys
I'm going back don't call me until I'm
ready
don't tell my tale about what happened
here today okay Oh apparently those were
the actors were the real deal
there were cyber scan in high resolution
in color that's why when I went so close
to sniffer armpit it felt like sniffing
your armpits all right this is so cool
I'm so excited about VR are you excited
basically you can experience this as
well on any VR platform so check out the
link in description to check it out
it will be available before the release
of the movie March 18 go check out
divergent guys tell ansell he's
beautiful and that was it for me for now
thank you for watching leave a like if
you enjoyed and I'll see breasts on the
other side brofist